I'm going to be living like Willy Wonka
for 24 hours I tried my hand at being a
greeter in the busiest candy store in my
town all while trying to not blow my
cover I don't know if they'll get upset
I'm I'm kind ofering welcome
guys thank you welcome thank you have a
good day oh an employee didn't F
outcome guys a lot of people probably
thought that I worked here
actually I'm not getting paid for this
really oh I'm sorry i w
welcome in guys energized and in the
true Spirit of Willy Wonka it was time
to whip up some homemade chocolate and
gummy bears let's start
with gummy bears oh yeah there we go you
still have blue left well I'll just
drink it okay on to chocolate is my OA
looma not going to help I was going to
make my
[Music]
brownies they're ready